is my honor to be back at the Munich
security conference
as many of us remember last year on this
stage
I warned of the imminent invasion
of Ukraine by Russia
and let us all recall
many at the time wondered
how we would all respond
many wondered
could Russia be stopped
would NATO come together
would NATO break apart
and wood Ukraine be prepared
colleagues today A year later we know
Kiev is still standing
Russia
Russia is weakened
the transatlantic Alliance is stronger
than ever
and most importantly
the spirit
of the Ukrainian people indoors
and under
Joe Biden president of the United States
our country has demonstrated decisive
leadership
as President Biden often says the United
States will support Ukraine for as long
as it takes
we will not waver
and today at this Munich security
conference
I will then describe
what we all continue to have at stake
the moral interest
the Strategic interest
and the reason Ukraine matters
for the people of America
for the people of Europe
and for people around the world
first from the starting days of this
unprovoked war
we have witnessed
Russian forces engage in horrendous
atrocities and war crimes
their actions are an assault
on our common values
an attack
on our common Humanity
and let us be clear
Russian forces have pursued a wide
spread
and systemic attack
against a civilian population
[Music]
gruesome Acts
of murder
torture
rape and deportation
execution-style killings
beatings
and electrocution
Russian authorities have forcibly
deported hundreds of thousands of people
from Ukraine to Russia
including children
they have cruelly separated children
from their families
and we've all seen the images
of the theater in maripol
were hundreds of people were killed
think of the image
of the pregnant mother
who was killed following a strike at a
maternity hospital
Where She Was preparing to give birth
think of the images of busha
civilians shot in Cold Blood
their bodies left in the street
the jarring photograph of the man who
was riding his bike
think of the four-year-old girl
who the United Nations recently reported
was sexually assaulted by a Russian
soldier
barbaric
and inhumane
long before I was vice president of the
United States
I spent the majority of my career as a
prosecutor
beginning as a young lawyer in the
courtroom
and later running the California
Department of Justice
I know firsthand
the importance of gathering facts
and holding them up against the law
in the case of Russia's actions in
Ukraine
we have examined the evidence
we know the legal standards
and there is no doubt
these are crimes against humanity
the United States has formally
determined
that Russia has committed
crimes against humanity
and I say
to all those who have perpetrated these
crimes
and to their superiors
who are complicit in these crimes
you will be held
to account
in the face of these
indisputable facts
to all of us
here in Munich
let us renew
our commitment
to accountability
let us
renew
our commitment
to the rule of law
it's for the United States we will
continue to support the judicial process
in Ukraine
and international investigations
because Justice must be served
let us all agree
on behalf of all the victims
both known
and unknown
Justice must be served
such
is our moral interest
we also have a significant strategic
interest
the fight in Ukraine
has far-reaching Global ramifications
no nation is safe in a world where one
country can violate the sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of another
where crimes against humanity are
committed with impunity
where a country with imperialist
ambitions
can go unchecked
response to the Russian invasion is a
demonstration of our Collective
commitment to uphold International rules
and norms
rules and Norms which since the end of
World War II
have provided unprecedented security and
prosperity
not only for the American people
not only
for the people of Europe
but people around the world
principles that state that Sovereign
Nations have a right to peacefully exist
that borders must not be changed by
force
that there are inalienable human rights
which governments must respect
and that the rule of law must be
preserved
indeed this moment
has tested
our willingness
to defend and uphold these rules and
norms
and we have remained strong
and we must stay strong
because if Putin were to succeed with
his attack on these fundamental
principles
other nations
could feel emboldened
to follow his violent example
other authoritarian powers
could seek to bend the world to their
will
through coercion
disinformation
and even Brute Force
the international order upon which we
all rely
could be at risk
so in the interest
of Global Security and prosperity
one of our defining missions
is to uphold
International
rules-based order and Nations around the
world agree
consider more than 140 countries voted
at the United Nations to condemn
Russia's aggression
Crane's sovereignty and territorial
integrity
in defense of the core principles of the
UN Charter
of course we have also seen Nations like
North Korea and Iran
send weapons and support of Russia's
brutal War
we are also troubled that Beijing
has deepened its relationship with
Moscow since the War Began
looking ahead
any steps by China
to provide lethal support to Russia
would only reward aggression
continue The Killing
and further undermine a rules-based
order
again the United States will continue to
strongly support Ukraine
and we will do so for as long as it
takes
the American people you see
are in awe
of the resolve of the people of Ukraine
in awe of their resilience and
righteousness
their willingness
to fight
for freedom and liberty
and the extraordinary tenacity and
Leadership of president zielinski
in fact joining me in Munich are
distinguished members
of the United States Congress
Republicans and Democrats
members of the House of Representatives
and the United States Senate
and they are here together
because they understand the stakes
the leadership of these members has been
vital
to America's support of Ukraine
and President Biden and I know that
their support for Ukraine will continue
we also know
Ukraine will continue to be supported by
a United
transatlantic community
foreign
[Applause]
thought he could divide NATO
remember where we were a year ago
in this he has failed
the NATO alliance is stronger now than
ever before
and the United States commitment to Nato
and to its Article 5 is Ironclad
just look at our track record over the
past year
just look at our multilateral
cooperation
together we have provided historic
assistance to Ukraine
Together We have dealt Russia a
strategic failure
together we have imposed unprecedented
costs on Russia
and together we have pursued energy
security and reinvested in our
Collective defense
and we have come together
to stand for our common values and our
common interests
and
our common Humanity
I have no doubt that this Unity will
endure
I also have no Illusions about the path
forward
there will be more dark days in Ukraine
the daily Agony of War will persist
the global Ripple effects will continue
to be felt by countries near and far
from Africa
to Southeast Asia to the Caribbean
but if Putin thinks he can wait us out
he is badly mistaken
time is not on his side
to be sure
ukrainians will continue
to be tried and tested
just as they have been over this past
year
transatlantic Unity
will continue to be tried and tested
and I am certain that Ukraine will rise
to the task
that the United States and Europe will
rise to the task
so my last point
America will continue our leadership
in defense
of human dignity
in defense of rules and norms
and in defense
of freedom and liberty
there is too much at stake
to do anything less
Americans know well
the meaning of Independence
we believe in the fundamental importance
of sovereignty and rule of law
and we will always stand on the side of
Justice
colleagues
I do believe we all know
When Future Generations look back at
this moment
they will see
that we understood the task before us
and Rose
to this occasion
and so to you I say
the United States of America is proud
to be your partner in this Noble Pursuit
thank you